welcome to this video eam Papa would tie
oops no wanted to play me five not King
e5 ok let's see Roy or not an Italian
game if he goes 95 I could play the
truck slaw just for the heck of it but
he went with the conservative route
castles hope you want ok always waiting
with castling in those positions i
always have this ok i know i can just
take very conveniently because now f
takes this is really not giving anything
with the rukon even ok there should be
six maybe it's not particularly exciting
but at least I'm like has no problems
here whatsoever
yeah I don't know about d5 but at least
the plate quickly yeah this is a pre
move I can entire they can only take a
few takes so this is ok that really
wonder what is what he is thinking about
it cannot really allow me to take ok it
seems he he wants to let me take
interesting takes no I jinx ok but I can
go here and then take with damaging a
spawn structure I mean b5 is not exactly
great to have this plate but it fields
feels a little bit difficult to believe
that it should be anything grateful wide
so I'm going to take it well I should
take I mean to make sure i get the
structure in the first place maybe now
f6 to cover cover a five and I need to
regroup the night now maybe 2d6 this
would be a good square to attack it for
me ok check I don't mind that at all i
really wonder why is he trading down to
a bad end game me now i'm not sure how
bad it is but it's definitely better for
blackjack ok so getting to d6 I guess
I am he maybe wants to put night on d3
as well in the night to see if i seemed
that's a decent idea that's not not easy
at all to make any progress with black
can get to be 6 with my king maybe but
he has got 96 hmm okay yeah that's not
so bad yeah I really thought that white
is just substantially worse but it's
probably not the case check I cannot do
very much he really
the same is actually true for white but
it seems that he is doing doing
something not sure then his night is not
exactly having many squares night a 7 s
getting cash wrapped and here this is
also looks kinda scary if I go King c7
like c6 King c 7 9 a-6 chick he can he
can keep it but it's not not easy but
first things first I rather I win one of
those pawns I'm going to take and take
you for I am can always go back by a g5
e6 and so on okay he tries to go to c5 I
can play c5 myself him King bee three
though it's not so that's not that great
okay let's keep this protected and then
go back why I e6 that's that's an easy
way to play check so see 5 or is there
something better yeah the night the
night to to d5 is also a good idea first
you fought check but then the night to
defy it sir it's a good jazz a good plan
before is a serious weakness that cannot
be protected anymore 95 he's got 94 hmm
that's not so great so
I can go inform then win dissing them
anyways now that's also not bad
intending king c4 maybe on or just 96
back on 94 I player for
Knight to f3 is also a way to win it I
think
okay now he has a hard time to move with
his pieces let's see c5 I can also yeah
okay this is this is good check check hi
morning yup ninety four ninety xp3 now
if i go here though I go with their 93
still has this 95 counter check maybe
this wasn't all that necessary okay
let's see what is doing now I can take h
two check check 42 42 passes
hmm
check sure it wasn't the greatest
technical play of all time but it is
enough check check white resides Jerry
yeah I should have won this a little bit
easier right but probably didn't spoil
it yeah it was a bit weird that he
traded everything off to this end game
where where he can really only lose I
mean not saying I'm better but he can
really only ever lose maybe it is it is
equal because of the c5 weakness but it
will be it will be not easy he has this
the sea for this is an issue not told
Joshua what what happened I mean he has
already misplaced his pieces no I'm just
winning winning this this thing's here
check I should have won yeah definitely
yeah maybe maybe 95 is still here but
kinky file is also the comp choice f4 I
have to play a form right okay I compass
on minus 6 and so on so I probably later
didn't check didn't it's always a
clearly winning for black so I was a
little bit in doubt if I made some
mistake there but it doesn't seem to be
okay wow thanks for watching